Hey boys cry if you didn't catch my
science of one punch man video.
My name is Helen and I'm here to up wise
cracks science games.
So thanks to brilliant.org
for sponsoring this video and join us as
we talk about everyone's favorite
holiday that institutionalizes the
extermination of the core.
The purge,
the purge is an annual free for all
crime spree that in theory allow
citizens to rid their wretched soul was
a deep seated desires by doing all the
murdering and pillaging they want for 12
hours without having to worry about the
Popo.
Well,
the government and the purge obviously
has social cleansing at the top of its
agenda.
Fortunately,
the citizens aren't killing enough,
so we supplement at all
to keep things balanced.
The ostensible reason for the holiday is
that if we can be super key for just one
day a year,
we can behave like model citizens for
the other 364 but would it work?
Can venting our anger somehow make us
less aggressive,
sharpen your hacksaws and cock your
glocks kids.
We'll take a look in this special
wisecrack edition of the psychology of
the purge,
and as always spoilers ahead.
The first film opens in a swanky
suburban utopia somewhere outside of la.
The media is fired up about purge night
like it's super bowl Sunday,
encouraging citizens everywhere to do
their civic duty and release the beast
when the clock strikes.
Seven American streets will be running
red tonight when people release the
beast in record numbers of Kelly getting
one last walk in before lockdown.
Yeah.
After all the experts say humans are
innately violent creatures,
pretending to be anything otherwise is
to deny our true nature.
The purge not only contained societal
violence to a single evening at the
countrywide catharsis creates
psychological stability by letting us
release the aggression we all have
inside of us.
So what is Catharsis anyway?
Psychology defines catharsis as the
process of experiencing emotional relief
through the release of pent up feelings,
especially pity for fear.
The concept comes from the Greek word
for purification or cleansing.
It dates back to the days of Aristotle
who postulated that watching tragic
performances couldn't do such intense
feelings of pity or fear that viewers
would ultimately be cleansed of these
emotions and his work politics.
Aristotle writes those who were subject
to the emotions of the fitting and fear
will necessarily be affected in the same
way and so will other men in exact
proportion to their susceptibility to
such emotions.
I'll experience a certain purge
catharsis and pleasant release.
The new founding fathers had been
feeding this idea to the masses for a
few years.
By the time the first movie opens,
even the otherwise benign sanded family
is down with the purge,
which isn't exactly surprising
considering James Profits big time from
selling security systems to his fellow
well-healed suburbanites.
Naturally,
James Repeats this logic to his son
Charlie saying that grownups have to
purge some times to get rid of all their
emotional gunk and that it's okay to
kill people for one night of the year if
it lifts your spirits.
Okay.
I know this is difficult to understand
that your age,
but tonight allows people a release for
all the hatred and violence and
aggression that they keep up inside
them.
The series also is loaded with baptismal
language with people justifying their
actions with words like cleanse our
souls.
Be Aware of about a thousand years or so
after aristotle made his claim about the
Cathartic benefits of theater.
Send bs thing,
cocaine,
Aficionado,
Sigmund Freud.
Your eyes that were pressing certain
kinds of negative emotions could lead to
the buildup of phobias,
the stereo or nervous outbursts.
One possible solution,
discharging the emotion by doing unto
others as they have to you.
In other words,
vengeance in there,
1895 book studies on hysteria,
Freud and his psych roadshows of Gloria
Rhodes.
The reaction of an injured person to a
trauma has really only a cathartic
effect if it is expressed in an adequate
reaction like event Brite embroiders
ideas on Catharsis for the foundation
for the hydraulic model of anger.
What suggested frustrations lead to
anger?
Anger leads to the buildup of negative
emotions and built up negative emotions.
Ultimately lead to an explosion of rage,
one where you might have just one of
those days.
We might go over off.
The theories that built on this idea
suggested that we ought to drain our
anger little by little rather than let
it all out at once.
In a way,
that idea is at odds with the type of
catharsis that's encouraged in the
purge,
which is more like saving up your
explosion of hostility rather than a
steady drain.
But the new founding fathers concept has
support in a theory by a quintet of
psychologists who published a book
called the frustration and aggression in
1939 the work postulates the aggression
is a consequence of frustration and that
aggressive acts lead to a reduction in
aggressive drive,
which makes it less likely that one will
act like this.
Inequality.
That sounds like it could have come
straight from the new founding fathers,
psychologist and author Dorothy Brook
Roche.
When Pasa cumulates and forms an
abscess,
the abscess must be opened and drained.
If this is not done,
the infection spreads.
In the end it may destroy the
individual.
Just so with feelings,
the badness must come out.
The hurts and fears and anger must be
released and drain.
Otherwise,
these two,
they destroyed me.
Individual.
This so called Catharsis hypothesis was
accepted until researchers actually
started studying it and one of the first
experiments conducted by psychologist
Robert Howard Hornberger,
a group of participants were insulted.
Then half of them were told to hammer
nails for 10 minutes,
a physical manifestation venting.
Afterwards,
they were given the chance to criticize
the person who did assaulted them.
If the Catharsis theory held true,
then pounding the nails would make the
disgrace participants less aggressive
toward the insults.
Instead,
the opposite happened.
The ones who'd hammered nails were
actually more hostile.
Subsequent research turned up mixed for
the Catharsis hypothesis and according
to our review of the evidence conducted
by Russell Geen and Michael Conti in
1977 a lot of the studies that had
indicated that aggressive behavior
reduced once tendency for violence had
methodological issues and when
replicated the results were the
opposite.
Canaan.
Quanti ultimately concluded that the
notion of Catharsis had not confirmed.
Psychologist Brad Bushman revisited this
idea in 2002 after having someone
insulted group of participants,
he had them either sit quietly in a
punching bag with the aim of getting
physically fit or hit a punching bag
while thinking about the person who
would insulted them.
Then he gave them a chance to confront
their and salter,
those who sat quietly were least likely
to be aggressive,
while those who had thought about the
person who insulted them with the most
likely to be aggressive.
The ones who hit the bag without
thinking about the insult or we're
somewhere in between.
This suggests that while getting all
worked up from exercise might have
increased aggression compared to sitting
quietly,
ruminating while acting out aggressively
was the most likely to amplify anger
overall.
A contrast to the catharsis hypothesis,
Bushman rights venting to reduce anger
is like using gasoline to put out a
fire.
It only feeds the flame.
Okay,
but is there any evidence that Catharsis
is a thing?
Maybe according to gene and Quanti,
there are circumstances where angered
people do seem to calm down if they have
the chance to retaliate against their
provoker,
but the context is pretty specific.
The retaliation should be justified and
the target can't be intimidating.
In other words,
expressing anger can be temporarily
calming if you aren't left feeling
anxious,
guilty or afraid that you were about to
get your ass kicked.
It should also be noted that in the
study cited here,
Bushman's experiments only look to
catharsis over a short window after
participant had been insulted,
which perhaps leaves open the idea that
aggressive behavior could be cathartic
over the long term is longer.
Studies on aggression mostly focused on
the impact of exposure to violence in
the media,
but that's a whole nother episode.
So if acting out your aggressive urges
doesn't relieve your emotional angst and
might even make it worse.
What does psychology has a couple of
suggestions.
We strategies like deep breathing,
relaxation and cognitive behavioral
therapy at the top of the list.
Something called primal.
Screaming has also been tested,
but the results were kind of
inconclusive and when it comes to
deciding whether to avenge wrongdoing or
let it slide,
it seems that forgiving or forgetting
might be better ways to free your inner
demons.
2008 study led by Kevin Carl Smith of
colgate university gives evidence that
people who have been wronged are less
likely to keep thinking about someone
who's offended them if they move on
without punishing them.
And another group of researchers have
developed a theory that even though
humans are hardwired to want to
retaliate against an aggressor,
they've evolved to forgive because it's
evolutionarily advantageous.
Well,
getting revenge against someone might
make it less likely that they'll hurt
you again.
We're telling iation also ruins the
chance to gain something from that
person later.
Thus according to their hypothesis,
forgiveness involved as a way for us to
have our cake and eat it too.
We get over the offense without losing
the chance to benefit from the
relationship later.
The idea that forgiveness is superior to
revenge is reflected in the purge
through all three of the films,
Mary Sand and chooses not to kill her
dick bag neighbors despite the fact that
they almost hack her children to death.
Oh,
for God's sake,
just do it.
Come on.
We're going to play the rest of this
night on.
Leo doesn't shoot the drunk driver who
walked free after killing his kid and
Senator Ron Alexa against often owens
after he attempts to have her
assassinated.
Even though doing so would not only have
served him right,
but also would have handed her the
presidential election,
which she winds up winning anyway.
It appears that the NFFA supporters
didn't quite get the memo about
forgiveness though as they're already
wreaking havoc at the end of the last
film and that bet big supporters are
reacting violently to this defeat.
They are burning cars,
so does the purge work.
There aren't any studies that let
people,
you know,
go on a homicidal rage for a day,
so we're going to err on the side of
caution and saying and everyone purging
by writing novels worth of anger,
Youtube comments.
It's not helping.
Sorry.
It's too bad because in theory,
this still limping.
Strangers really does seem like a good
way to blow off steam,
but let's talk about another theory like
what would happen if the earth suddenly
stopped spinning?
Obviously that would be bad,
but what would happen to the objects on
the surface when they fly off into space
along the straight line tangent to the
surface when they fly off along an
initial tangent before setting into
orbit,
would they fly along an initial tangent
before arking back to our humble planet
or what they skid along earth's surface,
following her sexy curves that you don't
know the answer,
but which she did want to prove me wrong
and challenge yourself with new puzzles
every week.
Head over to brilliant.org/wise
crack or click the link in the
description.
It's literally free to sign up and
they'll email you the solution.
You should work out your brain the way
you work out your body to survive the
purge,
and that means challenging your mind
with all of brilliance modules,
all of brilliance courses are made in a
fun arcade style that makes even
calculus fun.
Anyway,
go check it out.
If you're one of the first 200 people to
click on the link,
you'll get 20% off in annual
subscription.
What do you guys want me to dig into the
science of next?
Drop me a line in the comments and stay
safe out there.